a local mariachi director is a
semifinalist for the 2022 music educator
awards a big deal this is given out by
the recording academy and the grammy
museum so kate houston stopped by
mariachi hoya rehearsal at las vegas
high school to talk to the director
stephen blanco
we want to take this thing so seriously
to where we just want to put our focus
and our priority onto
texas mariachi hoya is rehearsing for
their debut performance at a major
competition in texas this december
leading the group is director stephen
blanco my philosophy in music and really
in life is just
if you work hard good things are going
to come at 25 years old blanco is a
semi-finalist for the national music
educator award it's a huge honor i'm so
happy for the exposure for las vegas
high school and for the mariachi program
the kids really deserve it
junior jessica halili has worked with
blanco since she was in middle school
and says she's proud to see he's being
recognized if we're tired of rehearsals
he just picks us up so quickly and
it's just like how one person can just
energize a group so quickly and how he
knows how much potential all of us have
blanco says clark county is spearheading
the growth of mariachi within schools
this year mariachi hoya performed at the
presidential inauguration and hispanic
heritage month celebrations in
washington d.c i'd like to think that
las vegas high school is really
plummeting forward in making sure
everybody knows hey
this is working you know our little
mariachi experiment that we did here in
clark county school district kate
houston live local now